Another Thing That Doctor Bright Is
Not Allowed To Do At The Foundation:
Dr. Bright must be informed that
SCP-018 is not to be taunted!
SCP-018 is also known as the Super Ball,
and it’s a small rubber ball created by
the Wham-O corporation, with the frightening and
destructive ability to bounce higher and faster
every single time it bounces,
resulting in rampant chaos.
So naturally, Dr. Bright has, on occasion, gotten
it out of containment to try bouncing it around,
likely destroying large amounts
of Foundation office equipment
and terrorizing all nearby staff members.
As such, his privileges around the Super
Ball have been revoked, and the O5 Council
has advised that Dr. Bright sticks to a
simple, non-anomalous paddle ball instead.